wenn ihr merken würdet dass ihr von
jemandem oder etwas total abhängig seid
was würdet ihr da tun einfach
weitermachen wie bisher und nicht drüber
nachdenken versuchen die Schwachstelle
der anderen Seite zu finden und sie zu
nutzen oder euch langsam unabhängig
machen hier geht's heute um
Beziehungsarbeit und zwar um die zu
China ein Land von dem Deutschland
abhängig ist wie von vielleicht keinem
zweiten das deutsche Geschäftsmodell ist
erledigt wollen wir das wirklich noch so
wir könnten uns unmittelbar im Krieg
wiederfinden
willkommen bei inside politics ich bin
Diana Zimmermann und arbeite im ZDF
früher war ich mal in Peking jetzt im
Hauptstadtstudio und die letzten Wochen
habe ich viel zur deutschen
chinastrategie gemacht was wäre wenn die
ganze schmerzhafte Abnabelung die wir in
den letzten eineinhalb Jahren von
Russland vorgenommen haben das teure Gas
und die astronomischen Benzinpreise nur
ein kleiner Vorgeschmack auf etwas noch
viel schwierigeres wären darauf nämlich
wenn sowas ähnliches mit China passieren
würde einem unserer größten
Handelspartner
lange glaubten oder zumindest sagten
deutsche Konzerne es sei richtig auch in
Länder zu investieren die die
Menschenrechte verletzen ihr Argument
Wandel durch Handel auch Diktaturen
würden sich durch gute
Wirtschaftsbeziehungen öffnen und
demokratischer werden irgendwann so die
schöne Theorie wären alle
Marktteilnehmer so eng miteinander
verknüpft dass es für alle Beteiligten
viel zu schädlich wäre in einen
bewaffneten Konflikt zu geraten globaler
Handel als eine Art Sicherheitsgarantie
mit diesem Argument und auf den riesigen
chinesischen Markt schielend investierte
z.B Volkswagen schon
1978 in China über die Jahre hat VW
Milliarden verdient Ende der 80er etwa
fuhren auf chinesischen Straßen fast 90%
VW gute 30 Jahre später aber haben die
chinesischen Autobauer die deutschen
abgehängt byyd ist der neue Marktführer
mit E-Autos nun bestaunt sogar der
Porsche und volkswagenchef bei der
internationalen Automobilmesse die
neuesten Modelle der chinesischen
Konkurrenz ich selbst war häufig auf
Automessen in China und kann bezeugen
lange haben die deutschen Autobauer die
Chinesen bestenfalls belächelt hinzu
kommt nun das Problem dass VW jedes
dritte Auto in China verkauft und mit
diesem Geld auch Investitionen und
Arbeitsplätze in Deutschland finanziert
und das geht nicht nur für den
Volkswagenkonzern als Russland die
Ukraine Angriff versuchte Deutschland in
wenigen Monaten von russischem Gas
unabhängig zu werden wir hatten 55 55%
gasabhängigkeit und wir haben es gerade
so geschafft dass die Volkswirtschaft
weiterlufen konnte 90 hätte uns die Füße
[Musik]
weggezogen zu 90% abhängig ist unser
Land aber in Bezug auf China von so
einigen Produkten die wir unbedingt
brauchen seltene Metalle und Medikamente
so wirklich wichtige wie Antibiotika
diese Abhängigkeit ist der
ampelregierung schon vor dem
ukrainekrieg aufgefallen deshalb hat sie
den Plan eine chinastategie zu entwerfen
in ihren Koalitionsvertrag geschrieben
super Idee könnte man meinen und nicht
gerade überstürzt wenn man bedenkt dass
deutsche Unternehmen seit 35 Jahren in
China investieren und wie sehr unsere
Wirtschaft vom Business mit China
abhängt der russische Angriff hat die
Dringlichkeit der Sache noch mal klarer
gemacht im Sommer stand dann die
Strategie die China als Partner
Wettbewerber und systemischen Rivalen
bezeichnet und damit aufschließt zur
Realität denn das China unter siinping
ist ein zunehmend aggressiv auftretender
Staat im Inneren wie im Äußeren und er
arbeitet mit aller Kraft an die
westlichen Bündnissen das kann man daran
erkennen dass sich China und Russland
seit dem ukrainekrieg bestens verstehen
Putin und Chi sich gegenseitig als guter
alter Freund und lieber Freund
bezeichnen China unterhält aber auch
enge Beziehungen zum Iran und hat z.B
die Terrorattacken der Hamas in Israel
bislang nicht verurteilt shidinping will
China zur dominierenden Weltmacht machen
das hat er nicht nur aufgeschrieben das
zeigen auch seine Taten und so z.B stößt
er immer häufiger Drohungen gegenüber
Taiwan aus wir sind bereit unser Bestes
für eine friedliche Wiedervereinigung zu
tun aber wir schließen die Anwendung von
Gewalt nicht aus und behalten uns alle
Maßnahmen vor die Volksrepublik China
betrachtet die kleine demokratische
Insel südlich von ihr als Teil ihres
Territoriums und hat so viel Druck auf
die meisten Länder der Welt ausgeübt
dass fast alle auch Deutschland sich zur
ein chinapitik bekennen also nur die
Volksrepublik und nicht Taiwan als
Nation anerkennen nun aber will China
Taiwan ins Mutterland zurückholen so
heißt das im offiziellen Wortlaut 93%
der Taiwaner wollen allerdings nicht
zwangsvereinigt werden das will chidin
Ping nicht hinnehmen und spielt immer
stärker mit den Muskeln schickt
chinesische Kampfjets über die
Mittellinie der Taiwanstraße und lässt
Kriegsschiffe in der Meerenge
[Musik]
kreuzen für unsere CDF Doku im Rachen
des Drachen den Link dazu findet Ihr ab
25 oktober unter diesem Beitrag habe ich
in taipe gedreht und konnte dort im
Präsidentenpalast mit dem
Generalsekretär des nationalen
Sicherheitsrates Wellington
sprechen china ist in der Tat
aggressiver als zuvor und verstärkt
seine militärischen Aktion gegen uns
entlang der Mittellinie der
Taiwanstraße der Hauptgrund ist
natürlich die Unterstützung der
internationalen Gemeinschaft für
Taiwan tatsächlich hat US-Präsident
Biden Taiwan versprochen zur Hilfe zu
kommen auch die deutsche Außenministerin
war bei einem Besuch in China
ungewöhnlich K eine einseitige und erst
recht gewaltsame Veränderung des Status
quo wäre für uns als Europäer nicht
akzeptabel ein Krieg zwischen China und
Taiwan das ist kein regionaler Konflikt
das würde sich sehr rasch ausweiten wir
sind mit einem Weltkriegsszenario
konfrontiert und Russland könnte die
Gunst der Stunde nutzen da die
Amerikaner dann im Pazifik gebunden sind
auch Europa auch NATO Territorium im
Zweifelsfall auch Deutschland
anzugreifen wir könnten uns unmittelbar
im Krieg wiederfinden selbst s wenn
dieses worstce Szenario nicht eintritt
und der Konflikt auf Asien begrenzt
bliebe hätte er massive Folgen für uns
allein der direkte Handel mit China
kostet uns wahrscheinlich 1 Million
Arbeitsplätze wenn wir uns da von heute
auf morgen loslösen müssen denn durch
die Straße von Taiwan wird etwa ein
Drittel bis die Hälfte des globalen
Warenhandels verschifft das heißt auch
das würde ja alles hier nicht mehr
ankommen das heißt wir hätten riesige
Engpässe und vermutlich auch eine
Massenarbeitslosigkeit warn rüstet auf
der Wehrdienst wurde verlängert die
Bürger trainieren teilweise
selbstorganisiert in nachbarschaftlichen
verteidigungsgruppen für den Ernstfall
Abschreckung ist die in ihren Augen
beste
Strategie wenn man die Erfahrung der
Ukraine auf taiiman
überträgt dann denke ich dass die
internationale Gemeinschaft China das
Gefühl geben sollte dass China die
wirtschaftssanktion Dritter nicht
aushalten könnte und dass es mit der
militärischen Intervention eines anderen
Landes rechnen
muss Taiwan muss sich allerdings nicht
darauf verlassen dass die westlichen
Demokratien dem demokratischen China nur
aus Solidarität zur Hilfe kommen würden
es hat sich eine eigene
Sicherheitsstrategie aufgebaut von der
wir nur lernen
[Musik]
können seit über 40 Jahren ist Taiwan
die sperspitze der Elektrotechnik
nirgendwo werden so viele und so
Leistungs Halbleiter produziert wie hier
diese winzigen Chips die in allem
möglichen stecken und ohne die heute
kein Windrad kein Auto und schon gar
kein Computer oder Handy funktioniert so
abhängig sind Asien die USA und Europa
von den Halbleitern aus Taiwan dass alle
Angst davor haben der Nachschub könnte
zusammenbrechen und genau das würde im
Falle eines Krieges natürlich passieren
Taiwan nennt seine Halbleiterindustrie
ein silicon Shield ein Schutzschild aus
Silikon es wirkt in den Westen wo man
sich plötzlich sehr solidarisch zeigt
mit der kleinen chinesischen Demokratie
und es wirkt nach China dort muss man
sich besonders wegen der Halbleiter gut
überlegen ob das Risiko eines Krieges
mit Taiwan nicht zu groß ist für China
aber ist das wichtigste Motiv um Taiwan
anzugreifen die territoriale Integrität
das erinnert verdammt an Russland auch
Putin ist ja der Ansicht die Ukraine
gehöre zur Russischen Föderation und
spätestens seit dem Krieg in der Ukraine
das haben mir in Taiwan viele meiner
Gesprächspartner gesagt sollte man
Drohungen von Diktatoren wohl ernst
[Musik]
nehmen was aber wenn die Abschreckung
doch nicht ausreicht Deutschland und
Europa wollen jetzt auch
industriepolitisch aktiv werden die
Bundesregierung kündigt in der China
Strategie an dass sie die Risken will
keine völlige Loslösung von China das
wäre auch gar nicht möglich aber eine
Reduzierung der Risiken 43 Milliarden
Euro wollen EU-Kommission und
Mitgliedsländer an Subventionen locker
machen damit in Deutschland Halbleiter
hergestellt werden Intel und TSMC aus
Taiwan bekommen jeweils mehrere
Milliarden für ihre geplanten Fabriken
in Magdeburg und Dresden Deutschland
entwickelt sich jetzt wahrscheinlich zu
dem großen Standort für die
Halbleiterproduktion in Europa das ist
wichtig für die Zukunftsfähigkeit
unseres europäischen Kontinents und es
ist wichtig ganz besonders natürlich
auch für die Zukunftsfähigkeit
Deutschlands auch gibt es eine
Diskussion darum wieder Antibiotika in
Deutschland herzustellen denn auch da
sind wir China ausgeliefert es gibt eine
Rohstoffstrategie die versuchen will die
internationale Rohstoffgewinnung breiter
zu streuen und möglichst viel in Europa
zu fördern und Europa will seine Muskeln
spielen lassen bei Produkten die die
Chinesen von uns brauchen ungewöhnlich
breit ist die Mehrheit in der Politik
die diese Kurskorrektur bevürwortet nur
AFD und Linke sind der Ansicht die
Abkehr von China sei falsch sie warnen
die risking mache Deutschland ärmer
koste Arbeitsplätze auch Teile der
deutschen Industrie bremsen die
Unternehmen haben die letzten Jahrzehnte
sehr viel Geld in und mit China gemacht
und sie hören nicht auf darauf zu hoffen
dass das so weitergehen wird VW und BASF
etwa haben im vergangenen Jahr
Rekordsummen in china investiert dabei
hat China selbst längst mit dem drisking
begonnen erklärtes Ziel ist es sich
selbst unabhängiger und andere Länder
abhängiger zu machen schon immer haben
deutsche Unternehmen geklagt dass sie in
China nicht so behandelt werden wie
chinesische Unternehmer und im immer
stärkeren bemühen autonomer zu werden
wird die Regierung es für ausländische
Unternehmen nur noch schwierig machen
wir werden den chinesischen Markt
ersetzen müssen weil langfristig unsere
Konzerne so in dieser Form in der wir es
jetzt sehen nicht mehr die Rolle spielen
werden die sie die letzten 10 20 Jahre
gespielt
[Musik]
haben wir kommen zu den Antworten auf
unsere Fragen vom Anfang den Kopf in den
Sand stecken hilft jetzt nicht sich zu
überlegen was der Gegenspieler von einem
selbst braucht stärkt die eigene
Position und läst den anderen womöglich
Zögern in den Konflikt zu gehen die
meiner Ansicht nach beste Strategie aber
ist es sich unabhängiger zu machen also
zu diversifizieren und nicht immer nur
auf den kurzfristigen Profit zu gucken
wenn Antibiotika und hebleiter die in
Deutschland produziert werden etwas
teurer sind dann muss es uns das wohl
wert sein denn dafür sind wir sicherer
vor den momentan wirklich vielen und
großen weltpolitischen Verwerfungen ein
paar exzessive Folgen der Globalisierung
zurückzudrehen ist nicht zuletzt im
Sinne ökologischer Nachhaltigkeit wenn
ihr Lust habt schaut die Dokumentation
im Rachen des Drachen die Elisabeth
Schmidt Thomas reicher und ich gemeinsam
gemacht haben sie steht ab 25.10 in der
ZDF Mediathek da könnt ihr auch sehen
warum ein taiwanesischer Reiseleiter zum
Kämpfen in die Ukraine gefahren ist was
denkt ihr über Handel mit Diktaturen
unser Verhältnis zu China und wie man
sich industriepolitisch aufstellen
sollte lasst uns gerne ein paar
Kommentare hier und vielleicht auch ein
Abo tschüss bis zum nächsten
Mal